er ist der samurai krieger des silicon
valleys einstellung ist wenn du gegen
mich antreten holst dann sei bereits
erklatscht zu werden larry ellison
startete oracle-software vor über 30
jahren und das machte ihn zum
bestbezahlten manager der letzten zehn
jahre geld mit einer vergütung von 1,84
milliarden dollar
niemand konnte wie larry einen kunden
glauben machen diese mit seinem produkt
dessen geschäftsleben verändern könnte
er sieht schon um die ecke lange bevor
andere das ende der strafe erreichen
um zu gewinnen
sap die deutsche software firma wurde
verurteilt oracle 1,3 milliarden dollar
zu zahlen oder auf dem meer es besteht
kein zweifel dass er es hasst zu
verlieren
die technologie seines unternehmens
wurde zum rückgrat der weltweiten
informationssystem von der regierung bis
zum online handel der dreiste milliardär
ist ein ehrgeiziger provokateur mit
einem einzigartigen führungsstil
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn sie irgendetwas über larry ellison
ist es wahrscheinlich ungefähr dass ihr
ich habe einen bugatti schnellste auto
geholt dieses haus kostet 200 millionen
dollar der schnellste segelboot das
jemals gebaut wurde ich bin süchtig
danach zu gewinnen er ist ein
adrenalin-junkie ein kompromissloser
sammler von teure spielzeug
2010 gab er 400 millionen dollar aus um
den america s cup die älteste
sporttrophäe zum ersten mal seit 15
jahren wieder nach amerika zu
aber die wurzeln seines erfolges sind
sehr froh noch einige wenige der
weltweit wichtigsten software tools von
denen sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht
wissen was seine firma sie zum laufen
dänemark
ist jeder auf der welt benutzt
bei allen möglichen transaktionen fast
jeder regierung der welt
jeder geschäftlichen transaktionen mit
fast jedem traditionellen oder internet
unternehmen der welt showbusiness wenn
sie eine kreditkarte haben weil sie ein
handy haben werden sie eher die eines
der modernsten dinge des lebens haben
larry ellison hat wohl die wichtigste
computer software entwickelt von der sie
je gehört habe er war der mann hinter
der riesigen veränderung unserer
lebensweise
blieb im hintergrund als wir versuchten
ihn für die teilnahme an diesem programm
zu gewinnen
1944 in der bronx geboren er wuchs
ellison in chicago auf
überrumpelte sein vater ihn mit einer
nachricht mein dad sagte kurz vor dem
abendessen ach übrigens du bist
adoptiert und heute abend essen wir
hackbrett es war so schockierend
ich habe es einfach verdrängt und
jahrelang darüber nachgedacht ohne mich
wirklich damit zu konfrontieren
ein mittelmäßiger schüler noch die
formale bildung
ist redakteur für die sankt petersburger
times und hat er listen für seine
biografie interviewt wollte keine regeln
befolgen weder eine schule in der
familie
er musste aus dem schatten von lewis
adressen hervorkommen und seinem vater
beweisen dass er etwas aus sich machen
konnte
sein gespür für die überholspur
offenbarte sich früh larry king los und
kaufte sich ein türkis blauen fahne da
war ein stylischer typ wollte die leute
beeindrucken stiegen dieses auto und
fuhr nach kalifornien
larry ellison hatte viel potenzial
seine reise nach kalifornien spielte
eine große rolle dabei wer werden würde
alison kam nach berg und verdiente sich
seinen lebensunterhalt als programmierer
1973 arbeitete er beim computer
elektronik hersteller amd will dort
lernte er stewart regan kennen der sie
sind seit über 35 jahren befreundet an
meinem ersten arbeitstag ging hier meine
kabine und auf der anderen seite des
flurs stand ein paar typen ihm nie zu
arbeiten schienen sie redeten die ganze
zeit nur und einer von ihnen redete nur
über sich selbst
sie dumm alle anderen waren und wie er
eigentlich alles leiten sollte
war ein talentierter aber ungeduldiger
programmierer der noch etwas suchte das
er selbst kontrollieren konnte zu sagen
er hätte die aufmerksamkeitsspanne eines
städten läufers wäre übertrieben wie war
eher die eines blitzes
das änderte sich als er einen job bei
der firma mpeg 1 mpeg
sex hatte mit einem projekt zu kämpfen
das von der
es tut den code-namen oracle dies
brachte ein system zum speichern und
abrufen großer mengen ausländischer
geheimdienst informationen die sich auf
sensible operationen und illusionen
bezogen vorerst für allison war es die
aufgabe seines lebens und säte den samen
für seine zukunft in den 70er jahren
wurden daten noch auf magnetband
gespeichert
für die cia zu unbeständig
zu langsam
xamax und gründete mit seinem freund
kommt dem programm youzhny bob miner
seine eigene firma
[Musik]
das technische talent dagegen hatte die
fähigkeit zu verkaufen die vision
die fähigkeit zu einem kunden zu gehen
und zu erklären so kann sich ihr
geschäft verändern mit diesem
handgeschriebenes schild und 1200 dollar
gründeten sie software development
er sagte er würde eine art firma gründen
und ich dachte das ist die dümmste idee
von der ich je gehört habe denn larry
war nicht berühmt dafür dinge zu ende zu
bringen ich habe immer gesagt er ist
eine totale niete aus dem wird nie was
ich hatte halt recht ellisons neues
unternehmen brauchte ein produkt und
nachdem er eine obskure ibm
forschungsarbeit gelesen hatte glaubte
er es zu haben eine methode zum
sortieren von informationen dass die
allen bisherigen überlegen war kam bevor
eine relationale daten für gary blum der
14 jahre mit alison zusammenarbeitete
war das ein komplexer name aber eine
einfache idee relationale datenbank des
platzes ist eine sammlung von daten und
informationen sie in ein format gebracht
werden dass es sehr einfach macht diese
informationen zu suchen und zu finden
sie kommuniziert
ibm sei das potenzial ihrer
möglichkeiten nicht
ich sagte oh mein gott wir können ibm
auf den markt schlagen weil ibm nicht an
seine eigene idee glaubt er wissen
glaubte und bat gott mit dem
programmieren zu beginnen für mich ist
es einfach eine coole technologien macht
spaß
die firma sei den markt wir waren uns
nicht sicher ob larry recht hatte aber
wir brauchten die
galerie stand unter großem druck
irgendwie geld reinzubekommen
unternehmen dabei eine datenbank
dass sie die art wie unternehmen daten
abrufen und verwalten
drei zimmer und ein kleiner lobby
bereich wir waren zu viert und schrieben
programme larry war damit beschäftigt
kunden zu finden und das war irgendwie
bizarr weise keine software hatten
also alles was sie in büchern lesen über
jemanden der ein anführer ist ja war es
nicht aber er war hartnäckig
neue crew und wurde zum wichtigsten un
botschafter das unternehmen
niemand hat besser auf geschäftsmann
gemacht er konnte kunden davon
überzeugen dass er mit seinem produkt im
geschäftsleben verändern
doch für das weltweite geheimdienst
management brauchten sie immer noch eine
intelligentere lösung
verkaufte seine datenbank an diese
seinen ersten kunden und nannte die neue
software version 2 es gab keine version
1 weil alle dachten naja das kauft doch
niemand also haben wir mit version 2
angefangen sie war mindestens so
fehlerhafte version 1 von irgendjemand
sonst ich nannte sie das kakerlaken
hotel der daten weisen die daten rein
mit kamen aber nicht mehr raus 1982 nahm
ellison den namen oracle auch für sein
unternehmen
erzielte auch seine sehr eigene weise
auf regierungsbehörden und große
unternehmen hat und ich erinnere mich
dass er mir sehr deutlich sagte wir
können nicht erfolgreich sein wenn wir
die kunden nicht an irgendeinem grund
erzählte larry der bank of america dass
wir 15 leute waren obwohl wir fünf waren
ich war mir nicht sicher warum die bank
an das von einem denken sollte wenn man
15 statt fünf ist barre larry hat ihnen
eine zahl gegeben die nicht stimmten
die auf einer japan reise in den frühen
70er jahren
ich habe dort mit einem geschäftsführer
gesprochen und er sagte das problem mit
amerika ist dass wir einfach keinen sinn
für wettbewerb haben
in japan glauben wir dass unsere
konkurrenten unseren kindern den reis
aus dem mund stehen und wir glauben dass
weniger als 100 prozent marktanteil
nicht ausreichend seien gehe über
leichen ansatz wurde
war bis mitte der 80er einfach mit allen
mitteln zu gewinnen
die einstellung ist wenn du gegen mich
antreten willst dann sei bereit
zerquetscht zu werden oder tritt nicht
gegen mittag
will oracle datenbank hob in einer
seiner anzeigen ab wie ein düsenjäger
bewährt und 1986 ging oracle und die
börse 29 und 30 prozentiger anteil am
unternehmen war beeindruckende 93
millionen dollar wert die der börsengang
war ein riesenerfolg wurde aber schon am
nächsten tag von microsoft börsengang
überschattet der bill gates seinen glanz
von 350 millionen einbrachte
1989 zog ihr wissen mit oracle auf dem
campus
kalifornien
eine anspielung auf den zauberer von oz
wie eine zeitung schrieb lair event und
jeder wusste wer der zauberer war
als ich einen ferrari 348 bestellte und
den ersten davon in kalifornien haben
wollte bestellte larry ein und irgendwo
an der ostküste und leasing verschicken
bevor ich mein bekam er wollte nicht der
zweite sein oder wollte der erste sein
seine besessenheit der erste zu sein
forderte ihren tribut oracle schlug
gegen eine wand dieser aggressiv und
verkaufspraktiken fingen an echte
probleme zu machen diese aggressiven
verkaufspraktiken in den 80er jahren
machten das unternehmen zum alptraum der
buchhalter die vertriebsmitarbeiter
waren so aggressiv und heiß darauf deals
abzuschließen so und gleichzeitig gab es
so wenig geschäftliche kontrolle
irgendwann bekommen wir das problem dass
wir schlechte verträge unterschrieben
haben sie verkaufen auch produkte die es
noch gar nicht dankbar dickel hat viele
futures verkauft sein nimmt eine menge
geld einen machtgewinn mit dingen du
erst noch kommt und
dann stellt sich die frage wenn du
endlich liefern kannst es an wen
verkaufst du hast es ja schon jedem
verkauf ist und zwar drei jahre bevor du
ins herz ist und dazu kam dass das
neueste produkt
die kunden waren frustriert
manchmal als die nahtoderfahrung
wir haben kein fett abgeschnitten
sondern muskelmasse und den einigen
fällen könnte man sogar sagen wir
schnitten ein tag mit maßen ab
mit dem freien fall des aktienkurses
schrumpfte auch
hatte er 790 millionen dollar verloren
[Musik]
dabei
versucht er
arbeitete die ganze zeit daran jetzt war
ja das gespann furchtbar für
wir sind ein haufen kinder die mit dem
geschäft aufgewachsen sind waren keine
kinder mehr als das geschäft war kein
kleines geschäft mehr es war jetzt groß
und wir mussten fast die gesamte
geschäftsleitung ersetzen das war ein
sehr schmerzhafter prozess
in das unternehmen einzusteigen
er brachte das mit was ich als operative
disziplin bezeichnet wurde die erfahrung
die ein großes unternehmen los es war
chaotisch schmerzen das wollte keiner
noch mal durchmachen
so wurde irgendwie alles auf null
gesetzt der wahre retter des
unternehmens kam jedoch in form eines
neuen produkts
der jüngste marketing
oracle 7 war ein spektakuläres produkt
viel die zukunft sei wieder rosiger aus
ich glaube ich jeder wusste dass damals
und konnte spüren
wurde nicht nur schrittweise besser
sondern um ganze prüfen
ellisons firma war der nahtoderfahrung
1994 überstiegen die einnahmen von
oracle die zwei milliarden dollar marke
die aktien waren fast drei milliarden
dollar wert
dafür ließen war das noch lange nicht
genug ohne das software schwergewicht zu
werden musste ließen den kampf mit dem
champion aufnehmen spiel
erschien persönlich enttäuscht zu sein
dass er nicht reicher war als bill gates
wenn du nicht die nummer eins fast wenn
du nicht der reichste wann warst du
nicht an der spitze du warst nicht der
beste im sinn verloren
ich denke dass larry dachte dass er in
einem riesigen wettbewerb mit bill gates
stand gates selbst hatte das vielleicht
gar nicht so gesehen aber larry wollte
als der größte innovator und verkäufer
in der software welt anerkannt werden
er hatte einen harten kampf gegen den
typen der seine software praktisch sind
jeden einzelnen pc der welt eingebaut
hatte
worauf gates fixiert später gab er
öffentlich zu privatdetektive angestellt
zu haben über ihn auszugraben games
neues produkt windows 95 begeisterte die
gesamte deckung
bei diesem auftritt
dieses windows 95 ist eine enorm
komplizierte software und dass die leute
das in ihren haushalten installieren und
managen sollten finde ich ein bisschen
komisch ich meine es wird zeit für etwas
das leichter zu bedienen ist das ist
teil unserer strategie microsoft
anzugreifen aber es bringt nichts da zb
geld zu werfen oder ihn zu beneiden man
muss über produkte nachdenken und
produkte entwickeln die besser sind als
die die microsoft verkauft
erlassen machte einen schritt in den
markt für verbraucher geräte
er brachte den computer mit großem
getöse auf den markt die computer die
derzeit herrscht sind ziemlich teuer und
sehr komplex also haben wir diesen neuen
klassischen computer ringen führt sehr
leicht kostet sehr wenig jetzt kann
jeder einen computer benutzen bei der
kostengünstigen gleich zu bedienen ist
und
er sagte
sozusagen eine art internet
ich kann mich an ein gespräch mit ihm
erinnern indem er sagte weißt du das
internet macht es möglich sich auf jedem
desktop eine welt vorzustellen
und das heute geburtsstunde des
ncs und versuchte sein baby mit einer
kampagne voranzubringen und machte sich
über den beliebten pc lustig
ich hasse den pc oder stellt das zeug
doch ins netz
gehören nicht in pappe und auf den
dann muss ich hin und mir das zeug holen
das ist verrückt ich
liebe das internet
doch als die pc preise fielen war auch
der lc zum scheitern verurteilt
ich glaube nicht dass an der idee etwas
falsch war ich glaube es war bloß zu
früh fünf jahre später hätten wir die
welt der oper
was haben die pc hersteller dell
gemacht haben einen 500 dollar bisher
entwickelt der super im internet surft
und e mails bearbeitet
auf dem verbrauchermarkt
war seinerzeit zu weit vom haus aber
seine vision vom internet ist zwar immer
noch genau richtig
oracle datenbank wurde zur grundlage all
der internet dienste die für uns heute
selbstverständlich sind
die speichern informationen rufen
information ab und liefern informationen
über die oracle daten
die leute dachten larissa verrückt
und es löste das größte problem der
geschichte im jahr 2000 gehörte larry
ellisons unternehmen zudem elite tech
unternehmen der welt
dabei interne kämpfe verdrängten bald
den geschäftsführer
der zum zweiten kommandeur und
thronfolger aufgestellten war
er beschrieb die kultur des unternehmens
das er verlassen hat es reicht nicht
wenn ein verkäufer seine quote erfüllte
er musste 200 prozent seiner quote
erfüllen die obersten zehn prozent haben
millionen bekommen und alle anderen viel
durchs netz sie sind schwache soldaten
lane sagte er passe nicht in das system
von oracle die einzige person die dort
entscheidungen treffen
waren verwirrt wer das sagen hat das ist
ziemlich unberechenbar talks oder zeigt
wie eine galaktische kollision bei der
zwei sterne aufeinandertreffen eine
ziemlich heftige explosion
oracle war auf dem vormarsch hinkt er
jedoch in einem wichtigen bereich
hinterher wir kämpfen immer noch um
relevanz bei den anwendungen wir sind
weltweit die nummer zwei bei den
anwendungen nummer zwei hinter sap erp
bereich junge diese zwei wird langsam
alt wir sind nummer zwei im crm hinter 7
aber wir wachsen schneller als sap und
siebel und wir sind fest entschlossen
die nummer eins bei den anwendungen zu
werden picasso wie wir die nummer eins
bei den datenbanken sind titeln die
nummer eins zu werden musste ellison
etwas tun was er lange vermieden hatte
durch übernahmen an neue technologien zu
kommen als er zu diesem schluss kam
öffnete er sein portemonnaie und setzt
die viel höher als jeder andere und er
tat es viel schneller als jeder andere
er wissen wollte neue anwendungs
software mit seiner produktlinie
kombinieren
2003 nahm er die firma peoplesoft bei
einem feindlichen übernahmeversuch ins
visier das justizministerium
verklagte oracle aus kartellrechtlichen
gründen eine übernahme würde das
unternehmen in die lage versetzen die
zinsen rechtswidrig zu erhöhen nach
anderthalbjährigen kampf stellten sich
die gerichte auf oracle seite
feierlichen kaufte peoplesoft für 10 3
milliarden dollar
es ist sehr selten dass jemand von der
regierung verklagt wird man gewinnt ich
meine das beweist nur wieder wie
hartnäckig dieser typ ist die meisten
jungs hätten wohl eher aufgegeben er
wissen nicht was in den nächsten fünf
jahren gab er fast 34 milliarden dollar
für den kauf und 52 unternehmen
heather bellini es geschäftsführerin des
technologie forschungsteams bei der
international
er schaute sich um und sah wie sich die
landschaft verändert und wie das
gemetzel das einigen seiner konkurrenten
angetan wurde immer die möglichkeit für
weitere übernahmen
um technologie zu kaufen hinter der herr
war er hat wirklich diesen ganzen
akquisitions lust steigerte sich 2009
mit seinem 7,4 milliarden dollar
schweren trophäen kauf von sun
microsystems dem führenden hardware
unternehmen
2010 richtete er seinen blick auf eine
ganz andere trophäe eine jahrzehntelange
400 millionen dollar obsession bmw
oracle racing und entstand im jahr 2000
für ellisons teilnahme america scca mit
dem vielleicht ältesten aktiven preis im
internationalen sport doch was ellison
schuh war vollkommen neu bebaut diese
träume das boot ist ein trimaran er lief
der zu fliegen scheint
die ozeane hatten so etwas noch nicht
gesehen
jetzt besteht absolut kein zweifel dass
er es hasst zu verlieren überhaupt kein
zweifel
maricas cup gegen edison angetreten
wir werden ja auch wieder gegen ihn
antreten dieser mann ist sehr
entschlossen zu gewinnen
am valentinstag 2010 brachte ellison den
america s cup zum ersten mal seit 15
jahren wieder in die usa
mit seiner jetzigen ex-frau der roman
autorin melanie kraft
der alte samurai krieger tauchte wieder
auf als sein freund marx als ceo bei
hewlett packard zurücktrat es ging um
vorwürfe der sexuellen belästigung und
unregelmäßigkeiten bei
spesenabrechnungen verließen war
entsetzt und griff den agp vorstand an
stand hat es gerade die schlimmste
personalentscheidung getroffen seit die
apple idioten steve jobs entlassen haben
einen monat später verblüffte ellison
die geschäftswelt als er den entlassenen
manager erstellt
die seifenoper von silicon valley ging
weiter als
apotheker zum ceo machte sein ehemaliges
unternehmen smi ist einer der größten
rivalen von oracle
die unternehmen waren in ein 3 jähriges
verfahren wegen urheberrechtsverletzung
verwickelt und das im november 2010 zu
ende ging
sap die deutsche softwarefirma oracle
1,3 milliarden dollar zahlen es war der
grösste vergleich aller zeiten für
software piraterie mit diesem schlag
hatte es ein neues blut und dem
schlachtfeld der informationstechnologie
vergossen und er ist entschlossener denn
je zu gewinnen sind
[Musik]
ein team das man liebt oder hasst und
als konkurrent von larry ellison weiß
ich dass es bei ihm auch so ist
wenn man bedenkt wie erfolgreich
während die meisten visionäre sich um
kopf und kragen reden und sagen oh so
könnte die welt sein sieht larry wie die
welt sein kann und versucht dann auch
sie so zu machen
er begann mit einer 1200 dollar
beteiligung an einem kleinen unternehmen
und baute es durch willenskraft zu einem
der größten softwareunternehmen der welt
auf
[Musik]